チャートにはいつでも1万種類以上のインジケーターを追加できます
その中でも地球上で最も優れたインジケーターは
価格がロングかショートかすら教えてくれません
気にも止めません
なんとサムネイルで明かしてしまったのですがATRです
ATRは平均深の範囲アベレージトゥルーレンジの略で
1万人のトレーダーにどれがATRになるかを予想させても
ATRを選ぶ人はいないでしょう
ATRを使ったことがある人なら
地球上で最も優れたFXインジケーターが何なのかという答えにきっと驚くでしょう
それでは早速始めましょう
この動画ではATRの仕組み
ATRとは何か
何をするのかそしてなぜ必ず使用すべきなのかを説明します
ATRを事前に確認せずに取引を行うべきではありません
だからこそこれは地球上でナンバーワンのトレーディング指標なのです
地球上のすべてのトレーダーが使うべき指標だからです
これほどまでに素晴らしい指標は他にありません
さてこの動画はもう少し後回しにしたかったのですが少し前に出しました
皆さんご存知の通り私はforexq&a podcastという番組を主催しています
ご存知ない方のために説明すると
リスナーの皆さんが私に質問をしてくださり
ののん先生4x.comスラッシュアスクブにアクセスしていただければ
私はできるだけ早くメールで回答します
こうした質問が番組のネタになることもあります
こうして皆さんのようなリスナーの皆さんからの質問によって番組が作られているのです
さて私が最初に制作したエピソード1では
我今天是在哪一家的質疑中的質疑中
我所在的アルゴリズムではどんな指標を使っていますか?
というものでした
私が使っているアルゴリズムは
それほど難しいものではありません
実はとてもシンプルで
例えば4から6個の指標に従っていて
それらが全てロングポジションを推奨すれば
ロングポジションを取り
全てショートポジションを推奨すれば
ショートポジションを取るというものです
これが私のやり方です
そして皆さんはそれらの指標が何なのかを知りたいのです
トレード方法を学ぶなんてくだらない話はやめてくれ
你把什么使用的呢
那你用的使用的
你用的使用的
答案是一直是NO的
听着的是你
这个人的用途
是不准的
这些用途
口座を三个破綻
何千時間もかけて家に帰って
有りとあらゆる設定
時間足
通過ペアで
这个可惜的因子
这个人的用途
今の組合
你达到的
你把你认为了
我认为你认为了
是正気
你不准的
但是その点は称賛に値する
この質問をしたことに腹を立てているわけではない
幸運は大胆なものに味方する
臆病なものには何も味方しない
だから大胆であることは素晴らしい
でももし君がこのアルゴリズムから何かを得ていると思っているなら
それは間違いだ
今日までATRがこのアルゴリズムの一部だとは知らなかったんだ
えっと理由はすぐに説明しますが
実はこれは私が全ての取引で使っているものです
なぜかチャートには入れていなかったのですが
すぐに理由がお分かりいただけると思います
首先, 这个顏料 什么的部分 它是什么的专言?我忘了這位置において私にとってアルゴリズムとは実際には全てが一致していなければならない一連の指標のことです全ての指標がねえvpこの通貨ペアはロングかショートかと指示しなければなりません
もし一つでも判断がつかなかったり反対の方向に動くように指示したりしたら私は何もしません
先に進みます常にトレードする必要はありません
我所在的方法、我所在的方法、 即是內部的インジケーター是
大手銀行的取引了取引所避的方法。
以前我所在的方法律的方法律。
人気無法、他人的方法律。
為何?
大手銀行的方法律。
多人的方法律。
是非人気が無くても私は彼らに可能な限り最適なタイミングで取引をさせたいと思っています
しかしそうなる前にまずどれくらいのリスクを取るべきかを知っておく必要があります
だからこそATR自動売買レートを参照する必要があるのです
これまでずっとそれが私のアルゴリズムの一部であることを忘れていたのは
すでにチャート上にX個のインジケーターを配置しているからです
これ以上インジケーターを追加したくありません
所以就是一部分的,但是這是足夠的,但是這是什麼最重要的,這是最重要的部分.
為何
誰もが価格がどこに向かうかを予測するのに非常に優れた単一の指標を求めているからです
しかしそのような指標は存在しません
互いを裏付ける指標の組み合わせが必要であり
そうすることで買いポジションまたは売りポジションを取るのに最適なタイミングを深く掘り下げることができます
しかし
ATRの何が最高なのでしょうか
それは
誰もが使用すべき唯一の指標だからです
皆さん
前にも言いました
これが最高なのはこの指標が存在しないからです
これは絶対に存在し誰もが使用する必要があります
これは人々が聞きたい答えではありません
なぜならこの指標には魅力的な点が何もないからです
誰もが魅力的なものを追い求めます
これは全く魅力的ではありません
誰もこの話を聞きたくありません
人々が求めているのは大きなトレンドに早く乗ったり
完璧な反転を予測したりできる指標です
彼らにはそのどちらも行わないものに時間をかける余裕はありません
この図からは離れましょう
えーとしかしATRは資金管理にとって非常に重要であり資金管理は勝利に不可欠です
私が作成した資金管理ビデオをまだ見ていない方は
このビデオも含まれる資金管理プレイリストのキックオフのような非常に短いビデオです
ぜひご覧ください
ATRはトレーディング口座の上昇または下降に最も大きく影響するものです
そしてATRは資金管理に関して最も重要な指標です
これが非常に重要であり私のリストの一番上にある理由の一つです
それでは先に進んでATRについて話しそれが何であるかを説明しましょう
そろそろそれをする時が来ましたか
平均審の範囲は特定の通貨ペアが過去X本のロウソク足で平均して何ピップ移動したかを示します
全てのプラットフォームのATRのデフォルト設定は14です。
つまり過去14本のロウソク足で上から下まで平均して何ピップス動くかということです。
これで終わりです。
分かりました。
それではすぐにチャートを見てみましょう。
設定方法とも少し詳しく説明します。
その前に取引にどのくらいの資金を投入するかという観点から取引エントリーを説明する方法を説明します。
明白吗?
単位で話していません
EURUSDをロングするために1万ユニットを投入しろとは言いません
そうは言いません
ドル金額でも言いません
PONDQEを4500投入しろとも言いません
1PIP当たりいくらで取引しているのか
PIP値はいくらなのかという言い方もしません私にとってそれが資金管理の観点から話す裁量の方法ですここからは 私が話す内容についてお話ししますユーロドルの1ロットは現在 1ピップ10ドルなのでロット単位
では話しませんしかし例えばユーロ ポンドを取引する場合これから
見ていくチャートの一つですが 1ロットは1ピップ10ドルにはなり
ませんですから特定の取引にどれ だけのリスクを負うべきかを判断
する上で私が本当に重視している のは1ピップあたりいくらの資金
を取引しているのかそしてピップ の価値はいくらなのかということ
ですさてこれで理解が深まった のでチャートを見てatrを確認
しましょうさてユーロポンドを 例としてあげますこれは他の通貨
ペアに比べて動きが非常に遅い ので良い例です
那是为了,有些人是在一起的工作。
那是,大家是平均14本的蝋子,
即14本的蝋子蝋子的ATR是在一起的,
我所要的的通知,有些人是在一起的工作。
我在家用冷やしチャートで取引するトレーダーなら podcast の第3話で説明したように金曜日であれば週の終わりまで待つべきですが
それ以外の曜日であればロウソク足が閉じる20分か30分前に atr を測定することをお勧めします
為什麼這麼做?
在這裡是因為它們的一天
從這裡開始的時候
在這裡開始的時候
就算了解決定的事情
所以,這裡解決定了嗎?
實際上,我們會有解決定的事情
就像是比較容易的
ATR是
ATR是,是全體的MT4的平台
是基本的,是有限的
所以,你提供的必要是沒有
我會有的問題
世の中にある最高のインジケーターの中には
いじる必要すらないものもあります
私は14期間で分析します
同じ色と線をそのままにしてOKをクリックするだけです
これでわかります
ではユーロポンドのATRはいくらでしょうか
誰か教えてくれませんか
ここにあります
41ピップスです
この線は時間の経過とともにどうなったかを示しているだけです
線は無視して構いません
嗯我
这就要在的一个设计上而在这个地方
评计划
这些计划有的计划是辆绝上上到下的这个平均
这些计划是远约数字的一样
有理由的那一筋划是有的这个计划是无法有的
这些计划是在一约的计划是有的
因计划是由于黑色似的计划是那么龙似的
可是我的计划是有的不足
你会把计划是雇有的
哦
看見通常ユーロ、ポンドよりもずっと大きく動いていますね
過去14期間を数えると1日当たり125ピップスです
今は1年の中でも動きが鈍い時期です
この通貨ペアは状況によっては200ピップス、時には300ピップスまで簡単に動くことがあります
8つの主要通貨ペアの中でこれは通常最も早くユーロ、ポンドは通常最も遅いです
所以,它是在2個比較,
是在每一種通貨的通貨配合必要的PIP値
是在哪一種通貨配合的方法,
所以,我回到的方法,
我可以解釋一下,
2個比較一下,
1個比例,
1個比例,1個比例,1個比例,1個比例,1個比例,ポンドキウイは125でした私は数学が苦手なのですが片方がもう片方の約3倍であることはすぐにわかります
ではどうすればいいでしょうか
まず現在ユーロポンドはポンドキウイの約3分の1の速度で動いていることを理解しましょう
そして逆にポンドキウイはユーロポンドの約3倍の動きをしています
さてこれは確立しましたね
ではどのように取引するのでしょうか
非常に簡単です
例えばユーロポンドを1ピップ6ドルで取引している場合
ポンドキウイを自信を持って簡単に取引できます
必要なのは取引額を1分の3減らすだけです
ここに1ピップ6ドルを投資する場合
ここに1ピップ2ドルを投資しても
結果は非常に似たものになります
私には当たり前のことのように思えますが
大多数のトレーダーは1ピップあたり同じ金額をこちらに投資しています
這個影片是有所看的方的多數是有所在的
這是資金管理的答案
這是大家的質問
為何要做的事情
這個人的方法
三倍自信有的事
是有所說的
其實你所說的事情
是別的
你所說的行動
這是非常愚蠻的無責任的方法
如果這個取引失敗的話
口座上大大打擊的方法
一度的損失的口座上大大影響
是不可不可
大家,こんな人不可
正式行動
ATR用來這個數據
其實是有所資金的方法
在這裡的資金
這個影片非常関連的方法
有很多人的方法
Episode 4 では、なぜもっと多くの通貨ペアを取引すべきかについてお話ししました。
多くの人がそうしない大きな理由の一つは、このような通貨ペアは値動きが激しいので、とても不吉で怖いと思われてしまうからだと思います。
でも、そう感じる必要は全くありません。
適切な額のピットバリューを投入すれば、他の取引と何ら変わりません。
これにより、取引の幅が格段に広がります。
為什麼會有少數的通貨只要取引不可
自分的取引範囲會有少許狭窮
會有可能性的可能性
成功や利益會有的チャンス
會有的方法
會有最悪的事件
是否有所要的事件
但是,有所要的通貨
可以使用的通貨
結論としてまず最初に理解していただきたいのは資金管理こそが最終的にあなたと 負けトレーダーを分ける唯一の要素であるということです
なぜならあなたの銀行口座の残高が上がるか下がるかは何よりも資金管理に かかっているからです
では資金管理において最も重要なツールは何でしょうか それは atr です
チャート上に atr を表示するかいつでも使えるように準備しておくべきです 特定の通貨ペアの atr が何なのかを常に把握できるようにしておきましょう
常に100%常にATRを表示させておくべきです
ATRなしで取引をすることは絶対に避けてください
それほど重要なのです
さて私ほどFXの資金管理を深く掘り下げている人は他にいますか?
誰もいません
まさに最も重要なことです
そして多くの人がこのことについてもっと語らないことで
あなたに大きな損害を与えています
ですから本当に成功したいのであれば
何をすべきかは分かっているはずです
このチャンネルを購読してください
私たちはまだ全てにおいて始まったばかりです
もちろんエントリー方法や
最適なエントリーの獲得方法についても解説します
本当に役立つとっておきの情報です
全てはそこにあります
えーと
でも資金管理は絶対に必要です
誰もが間違いなく
これが得意だと分かっているはずです
だってこれをやれば後は簡単ですから
さあチャンネル登録して
ベルを鳴らして
何も見逃さないでください
ポッドキャストをチェックして
ののん先生4x.comをチェックしてみてください
動画ポッドキャスト
ブログなど全てが揃っています
そして
あなたの成功に特化した
youtube channelをフォローしましょう
これらを全て組み合わせてさあ始めましょう